ciao
oggi
rappresentiamo un gruppo di amici che è
anche un arco un ragazzo architetti lavoriamo
principalmente nel contesto dell'emergenza uomo italiana
e con un
budget economico stressante quello che cerchiamo di fare è
trasformare questi limiti in opportunità
che utilizzando tecniche ripetibili
ovunque da chiunque lavori  con
tutta la comunità e in fondo non quattro
senza dimenticare l'estetica degli
edifici l'opportunità di fare quello
che mentiremmo nel nostro lavoro nasce
da una richiesta di una ONG un lavoro italiano
nel terrore che ce lo ha chiesto
a costruire e asili e alcune
scuole in un territorio occupato della
Palestina in questo periodo la maggior parte dei miei
colleghi ed io stavamo lavorando per
l'Università italiana dove stavamo
conducendo uno studio teorico sul tema della
sostenibilità ambientale quindi per noi
è stata l'occasione per  combinare la nostra
ricerca con i bisogni sociali che era
esattamente quello che vorremmo fare quindi
ovviamente accettiamo la sfida ma
la prima  il problema sarebbe presto arrivato Voglio
dire che la scuola che la ONG ha chiesto di
costruire era in un villaggio beduino
nell'estrema periferia di Gerusalemme quindi
dovevamo andare a lavorare con la popolazione dove
c'era una barriera linguistica totale
ovviamente noi italiani avremmo tutti  parlare
per mano ma in questo caso
non bastava anche perché ad esempio
se
diciamo qualcosa di leggero quello che stai
facendo è qualcosa del genere a in un
linguaggio del corpo beduino significa aspettare e
quindi il cantiere era f era un  grande diventa
confusione alimentare e quindi reagiamo a questo
questo problema abbiamo affrontato questo problema
e il creatore di Bill creando in una sorta
di modo strutturato che ora
non funziona che è una sequenza di
illustrazioni e quella da seguire passo
dopo passo per costruire  la scuola o
qualsiasi edificio che stiamo cercando di fare per
costruire questo manuale è un attraverso questo
metodo possiamo garantire le
fasi di costruzione ma tesi ma
anche la manutenzione a lungo termine
dell'edificio  dove non stavamo più
supervisionando il sito prima di andare a
lavorare con questi prima di fare
questo manuale lavoriamo in un seminario in
Italia per garantire la tecnica che
prevediamo di applicare per fare che avviamo
un war shopper in Italia  e abbiamo
sperimentato costruendo un prototipo in
scala uno a uno intendo in una dimensione reale reale
per valutare siamo in grado di
valutare le tecniche che andremo
ad utilizzare e anche le scelte tutto il
materiale che utilizzeremo in questo modo
lavoriamo con un metodo che valuti
sia le
conoscenze teoriche ma anche pratiche pratiche ciò che vogliamo fare
è lasciare una conoscenza che
potrebbe migliorare la qualità della vita nella
comunità in cui noi lavoriamo intendo
questo surfista questi  questo la gestione
dell'approccio alla costruzione dell'auto è
diventata una parte fondamentale del nostro
intervento su cui vogliamo lavorare per creare
la condizione in cui la comunità
potrebbe lavorare potrebbe costruire il proprio
edificio per farlo al fine di d  o che
dobbiamo prestare dolce attenzione ai
materiali che devono essere riciclati o
naturali il principe il principio attivo passivo
dell'architettura bioclimatica
e anche le tecniche che utilizziamo
provenienti dalla tradizione locale o un
affittuario in possesso di un adattamento al
contemporaneo devo  bruciare la
prima scuola che abbiamo costruito è stata nel
2009 era la scuola del titolo era un
costruttore totalmente con pneumatici tutti gli
pneumatici standard per auto questo più fresco ero il
per dire che dobbiamo completare tutta la
scuola per terminare la scuola con
15.000 euro poi l'immaginare l'iconico
immaginare il nostro limite della scuola attira
l'attenzione di molti giornali che si
aggrappano alla scuola e arriviamo
a fornirgli foto, pannelli e
diverse cose del genere poi
ricostruiamo in un villaggio edificabile  in
un'altra scuola la scuola di bambù che si trova
in mezzo al deserto
non era nell'area sotto il
controllo militare di Israele e quindi nessun
permesso è stato fornito per nessun n  Nuovo
edificio siamo riusciti a costruire la scuola
isolandola a poppa con il bambù
utilizzandola come protezione solare sternale e nella
parte interna con uno strato di argilla
e paglia così con qualche semplice gesto
si arriva a migliorare la qualità della vita
e la  performance di questo questo
edificio il primo obiettivo era nella Striscia di
Gaza spostiamo la nostra tensione da una
Cisgiordania alla Striscia di Gaza dove il
conflitto il livello del comitato è
molto molto stretto in questo caso costruiamo
un asilo nido nel centro femminile e
scegliamo  per usare la borsa la sua borsa che è
la luna è principalmente un sacco lungo
riempilo con la terra posiziona uno sopra l'altro
fino a quando non si raffredda fino a raggiungere l'
altezza desiderata questo dispositivo di raffreddamento è stato fornito con
un sacco di roba come un'operazione di
filtro dell'acqua e  il pannello solare, ma
ciò che è importante in questo obiettivo
è fornire alla comunità un
luogo sicuro per i bambini e un
luogo in cui le donne possano essere una
dignità personale nel contesto in cui
la religione fonda  l'entalismo è molto
molto molto forte questo potrebbe arrivare a
resistere ai 22 bombardamenti ma
purtroppo nell'ultimo conflitto nel
luglio duemilaquattordici è stato distrutto
da un bulldozer e quindi ora non avevamo
scuola nella striscia di gaza
spero di  hanno chiarito che per noi
non c'è sostenibilità se
ambiente ambientale fattore sociale ed
economico dozzine di quiz nello
stesso momento in cui l'
Università italiana non era interessata alla
nostra ricerca decidiamo di farla
autonomamente finanziando nella nostra cooperativa un
arco a cadetto  operazione di rango che funziona
che applica la ricerca su tutti
questi problemi che vediamo fino ad ora grazie